hey what's up guys i'm pbht here and
this is Apollo where this is least what
I've named her this is a Tesla Model S P
100 B this is a brand new car it's a new
Tesla you've probably heard of it I've
talked about it a lot before I've
mentioned it in videos I've talked about
it on Twitter etc I just took delivery
of this car so as far as I'm concerned
and what Tesla told me is that this is
the first P 100 D on the east coast of
the United States delivery was today
that I'm shooting and editing this video
and I want to share it with you guys now
I'm also shooting this video as you can
tell a much more live style on the
iPhone 7 plus camera so that's the
stabilization and that's the 4k video
you're seeing figured this was a pretty
good opportunity to test that but yeah
this is sort of a I kind of decided just
to do these two videos at the same time
iPhone 4k camera test
Tesla T 100 D first impression I
actually kind of think would be fun to
make this a sort of a beginning of a
playlist this would be the first video
and an evolving playlist because this is
a car that as you probably already know
is really high-tech it's a piece of tech
and it involves two so this will be the
first video in the playlist if that
makes sense
so I guess give a thumbs up if you like
that idea but essentially this gives me
a chance to test the 4k cameras on new
smartphones and lets me show new
features of the car as they come out so
this first video this first video in the
playlist is a sort of a walk-around and
a first look at the car at the
all-electric car for those of you who
aren't familiar this will give you a
pretty good look this is the key to the
car auto focus oh good job iPhone this
key fob will control everything about
the car behind it as you can see so
there's actually buttons it's the shape
of the car but if I double press the
back of the car here right behind it
it'll open up the back of the car and
there's plenty of storage in the back
like a lot of storage as you can see
here before the seats down it'll go even
further there's also this little area in
the bottom here which will open up to
get to even more storage that's where I
have my charging cable and a big part of
picking this vehicle over pretty much
any other vehicle is that is huge for
carrying equipment for video equipment
video equipment big I can close this by
double-tapping it again or just by
reaching up here
pressing that button and there's plenty
of other features that I can go around
but there's also that little mini
spoiler on the back and then up here at
the front of the car is what they call a
front trunk or a front that auto focus
is good okay so I DoubleTap the front of
the car that pops back this is an
all-electric car so there's no physical
engine either it's just electric motors
between the wheels and a battery so
there's a little extra storage space in
there and some stickers and some
windshield wiper fluid and there's a lot
fun part flighty guys you don't know let
me 2x zoom here you can see the handles
on the door are flat and flush to the
car when you have the key fob with you
and you walk up to the car they'll kind
of detect that you're approaching it
it'll unlock it and the door handles
come out and present themselves and
that's how you get in now there's a lot
of other things that I'm going to show
you guys with the software in future
videos because this software right here
is a big part of what makes this car run
this is the version 8.0 software already
and there's a whole lot of things you
can do with this touchscreen that again
software updates will change you have
driving controls you have the ability to
open the sunroof just by scrolling down
on that I'm telling you all the vehicle
controls are in this big screen right
here so that's that could be a video all
by itself if you want that now I don't
know exactly how much I'm going to be
panning out this series in two different
videos whether it's like three or four
videos or like 10 or 20 but you can see
here I mean this car has auto pilot the
stock is right there you can drive
itself or you can drive like a normal
person the interior is a lot more
spacious than you might imagine because
there's no transmission to take up space
in the middle so there's this big ol cup
holder here there's more stuff in the
middle and lastly I want to mention I'm
a tech guy before I am a car guy but
this is pretty much as high-tech as it
gets as far as cars go so the P 100 D P
stands for performance 100 stands for
the size of the hundred kilowatt hour
battery pack in the bottom of the car
and D stands for dual motors
and a little underlying actually
signifies that it's part of the Ludacris
mode Justin goes from a dead stop
to sixty miles an hour in exactly 2.5
seconds so that that technically
technically makes this the fastest
production car on planet earth right now
others like the Bugatti there and a
Porsche 918 spyder aren't really made
anymore so bad thing if you're not in a
Bugatti you're getting beat off the line
by so that's pretty much it for now guys
again this is a super short video but I
wanted to share and there's gonna be a
lot more that I can share and I guess
feel free to leave your comments in the
comment section below of what features
of this car you want to see outline and
highlight it on video and what types of
things you want to see later in this
playlist so that's been it for this very
short video guys thank you for watching
this first on Apollo I'll talk to you
guys the next one Pacey
[Music]